let's get back to the phone lines I've
got dawn on the line
dawn how are you hi Don Murray how are
you I'm sorry young lady how are you
today that's okay I'm just freaking
fabulous and I want to be fired up
because we're just starting this journey
sure my my question the truth the short
side of the question is I know he's been
a fairly decent saver and we're on the
every dollar budget and he knows where
all of the money is and I have about
sixty four hundred dollars in a
certificate that's at a three point two
percent rate and it matures in September
our two lowest debts when it's $10,000
at 0% interest and the other is a car
car note at twelve thousand dollars at
six and a half percent okay should I
should I take that sixty four hundred
and pay towards one of those should I
leave it there and let it grow and roll
over because I really want to get I
really want to make headway right so
these are the only two debts you all
have okay what else do you guys oh there
is another vehicle and then life
happened and there's a credit card
balance and a personal loan okay so how
much is the other car loan that's about
twenty thousand okay and how much is the
credit card the credit card and the
personal loan is a big chunk of it that
that's about the forty seven thousand
dollars combined whoa did you guys
consolidate debt I tried to while he was
trying to start some start a business
and I didn't know he was doing that and
then they told me he was in trouble
then I was like let's get personal loans
those consolidate and students well he
couldn't qualify got you
are you married are you guys married and
and so well that's what I was getting
ready to say you were doing some
specific pronouns you said his okay good
that one here on my head was about to
get riled up so I'm glad you got you
gotta be in this thing together doing it
the right way Don Murray here's the deal
I like that you guys are focused right
now because you do you've got a whole
plethora of all types of debt here
I like the idea I've definitely taken
that money and putting it toward the
$10,000 debt without a doubt because as
we work the debt snowball this is gonna
be about working smallest to biggest
it's not about math it's about momentum
and so you get focused and you get
intentional and I like that you guys are
together in your bank account you're
talking about this and you're looking at
it and you see it for what it is right
now you're allowing all of this debt to
steal your income so you're working
really really hard and not feeling like
you're making any kind of progress and
so taking a stand for this this is going
to be crucial you guys doing this
talking about it together there's no
more one person trying to do something
than the other I want you to be unified
in this talking about it looking at it
for what it is but I want you to get
your future back and when you get out of
debt that's exactly what happens and you
do have to be focused you do you have to
start to get frustrated and I want you
to get mad at the debt get frustrated
and irritated at it but I want you to
understand you can control your your
momentum and how fast you go and so you
look at this and you look at taking on
extra jobs if you have to do on every
dime of that money toward debt but you
have to get to that point of where
you're sick and tired of being sick and
tired and you get ish irritated and
frustrated at the debt but continue
working together in unison talking about
this and really really digging in and
looking at it because I get people that
will say I'd really want to get out of
debt I want you to know you're why what
is that thing that's motivating you
what's gonna cause you to run faster
than you ever have before and when you
start to think about those dreams not
only the things you want to do for your
but the things you want to do for the
people you love the most it's a game
changer because now you see it in
high-definition and I tell people to
look at it in high-def I talk about that
in my book retire inspired but people
didn't get it and when I went into an
electronic store I was looking to go
replace a dryer and I saw this
high-definition TV I saw a picture like
I'd never seen before
the grass was swaying in the wind and I
saw sweat about to come out of
somebody's pore this is how clear this
TV was and I thought my goodness and it
hit me a few weeks later if I can get
people to see their dreams as clear as I
saw that picture on that TV it's a game
changer because now you're not just
talking about traveling you see yourself
in Hawaii you see yourself in Alaska you
see yourself writing that check for that
charity that you care about and things
get real and that's what I want people
to do I want it to be so tangible you
can touch it because then you'll get
intentional about working day in and day
out to keep you on that trajectory and
it's very very very important and so we
have to stay motivated we have to stay
clear on what it is we're trying to
accomplish thank you very very much for
that call